[Musique]
bienvenue sur le plateau d' à tanis
d'interdire je reçois aujourd'hui par
skype thiery nélias pour son livre
l'humiliante défaite sur la guerre
franco-prussienne de 1870 dont on
commémore cette année le 150e
anniversaire et à liu chia valdes
lasowski qui publie les cinq secrets de
james bond
une relecture des 25 films de la saga du
premier james bond contre dr no en 1962
jusqu'au 25e mourir peut attendre qui
sortira en novembre
et l'on commence tout de suite par
l'humiliante défaite 2-1 elias qui
paraît à les librairies vibert la guerre
de 1870
c'est le premier acte du conflit franco
allemand qui va s'étaler sur 75 ans
l'alsace et la lorraine que nous avions
prise aux allemands aux xviie et xviiie
siècles est rendu à ce moment-là à
l'allemagne où l'âge où les récupérera à
l'issue de la première guerre mondiale
en 1918 on les reperdre en 1940 et on
les reprendre a définitivement en 1945
alors la question que l'on peut se poser
thiery nélias c'est pourquoi cette
guerre au fond pourquoi napoléon iii qui
avait réussi à rendre à la france sa
primauté militaires savaient pas été
facile au 19e siècle après les longtemps
après les victoires napoléoniennes
pourquoi ils se risquent dans une guerre
contre la prusse qui est devenue une
très grosse puissance militaire à son
tour qui vient de de battre l'autriche
le danemark
pourquoi se laisse-t-il entraîner dans
ce conflit bien bonjour suite aux délits
et merci merci pour tout part d'une dune
guerre de succession un peu un petit peu
à l'ancienne alors c'est un peu le
paradoxe de ce conflit c'est à dire que
c'est un conflit qui est vraiment très
moderne et qui dit filaments débute par
une jolie somme de vulgaires succès
cieux guerre de succession
c'est à dire que le la reine de reine
d'espagne va va comment dirais-je
abandonner son trône deux ans auparavant
et le trône est en ouvert guillaume
premier va va finalement trouver un
proposer un successeur qui sera à
léopold ii hollande zoller pour succéder
à la reine d'espagne sur le trône et est
donc évidemment ça ne plaît pas du tout
à la france y est napoléon iii puisque
effectivement ça sarah vivre elle le
vieux complexe d'être enserrée entre les
as bourguet et du royaume d'espagne
qu'avait déjà utilisateurs à ce moment à
son époque donc napoléon iii vraiment
tout faire pour
pour que le pour que comment le
le prétendant retire sa candidature il
va réussir dans un premier temps mais
sur la pulsion du ministre-président
bismarck la la sphère va être
représentée à nouveau et du coup vers le
mois de juillet au début du mois de
juillet napoléon iii va envoyer son son
diplomate et de vélizy à la rencontre de
deux quais au premier théâtre en train
de prendre les eaux à m pour essayer d'
absolument de négocier une rue un
retrait de la candidature hollande
zoller ce qu'il va réussir dans un
premier temps effectivement puisque le
puisque guillaume premier lui lui
accorde que finalement il n'aura pu
prétentions sur trop de l'espagne et est
ensuite envoie donc une dépêche à son
ministre-président bismarck en prusse
afin que celui-ci préviennent que la
presse comme quoi finalement la
candidature est abandonnée sauf que
bismarck eux ne l'entend pas de cette
oreille parce qu'il a vraiment besoin de
cette guerre contre la france pour
unifier tout jeune semaine c'est-à-dire
rapatrier les états du sud dans la
confédération une heure qui existe déjà
et il va donc habilement faire une
traduction un petit peu tendancieuse
il y apporter des omissions et de
rajouter quelques quelques quelques
quelques mots en fête qui finalement
change complètement l'esprit de cette de
cette dépêche est partie vraiment la
dépêche et elle est diffusée dans la
presse ça devient une un véritable
brûlot et toutes là tout le piment
française à la presse française
s'enflamme contre cet affront qui est
fait à à bord et gym gym français la
dépêche c'est la dépêche dems
guillaume premier c'est le roi de prusse
on est on est où sont face à face à ce
moment là se retrouvent face à face
pendant cet été caniculaire de l'année
1970 l'armée française était considérée
comme la première arme et d'europe et
face à elle
l'armée prussienne mais sauf que l'armée
l'armée française dont tout le monde se
dit que c'est la meilleure armée du
monde en fait va se battre à un contre 2
vous le raconter et puis surtout les
prussiens une très grosse supériorité
dans le domaine de l'artillerie c'est ce
qui va faire emporter la décision en
plus ils sont meilleur tactiquement bien
que les français et les premières
mitrailleuses et ça va être un conflit
particulièrement sanglants entre les
mitrailleuses les canons groupe
ça tue énormément c'est une guerre très
très moderne celui dont on sait chaque
chaque bataille déjà mais on en met en
scène plusieurs dizaines de milliers de
combattants et en général ce sont ce
sont très souvent entre dix et vingt
mille morts blessés et disparus
à chaque bataille ce qui fait que quand
on est un peu les récits par exemple
demander des soldats français mais
également les récits des soldats
quotient s'aperçoit que c'est parfois
terrifiant si en tant qu' effectivement
c'est une mine
on est à l'orée d'une nouvelle ère de la
guerre de la guerre de masse et la
guerre de destruction d'ailleurs quand
on regarde cette année certaines images
par exemple de de strasbourg appartenant
à la ville s'est rendu après le siège ou
certaine image de la banlieue parisienne
après les bombardements à n'aurait
absolument rien à envier à celle de la
première et de la deuxième guerre
mondiale par exemple alors ce conflit
cette guerre à proprement parler elle va
durer seulement quatre semaines c'est
très très court et ça donne
immédiatement belle image de sedan la
fameuse bataille de sedan qui va opposer
cent vingt mille français à 200000
prussiens le l'empereur napoléon iii et
est enfermé dans sedan avec les français
et il est battu et là au bout de quatre
semaines en fait c'est plié un les
prussiens ont déjà gagné sauf que
napoléon se rend à bismarck
mais ça ne suffit pas la différence on
est on est dans un cas très similaire à
celui de juin 40
on s'est fait battre à plate couture
très rapidement sauf que là la
différence l'empereur a beau se rendre
les français en tout cas il ya un
gouvernement provisoire qui est mis en
place à paris avec des députés
républicains il y aura gambetta et jules
favre et y résistent et en fait les les
allemands se dirige vers paris c'est une
promenade de santé c'est l'exode déjà
comme en juin 40 les rues de l'exode des
français
mais là on résiste c'est vraiment la
différence avec juin 40
c'est ça c'est à dire que la la victoire
des prussiens à ce moment l'année n'est
pas complètement n'est pas complète si
on n'est pas totale c'est à dire que
l'essentiel du pays et sauf à ce moment
là et ça aurait même très bien pu en
rester là c'est à dire que partiellement
ou le napoléon iii est embastillé à
castle en allemagne il ya six moments de
flottement on va dire de quelques jours
ou guillaume 1er et son staff et
notamment bismarck s'interroge à savoir
s'ils vont aller sur paris où finalement
conservé leur victoire dans l'est
conservez effectivement le napoléon
prisonniers de façon à installer un
nouveau gouvernement qui serait qui se
prête donc
l'issue de ce chiffre est en fait tenu
par par l'héritier de napoléon iii donc
le prince héritier qui serait finalement
assez commode à manipuler par la suite
et finalement c'est l'option d'aller
vers paris qui était choisie quand même
et à ce moment là en fait là là lui
comme vous dites que des pros fermé et
donc il ya un gouvernement de défense
nationale qui secret et on fait un appel
ont fait appel à tous toutes les
volontés de france et de navarre pour
venir converger vers paris et est stoppé
l'avancée cruciale
donc on monte à la hâte en fait des
armes et notamment la fameuse armée de
la loire fait à partir de mobiles la
plupart du temps de francs-tireurs
également qui viennent appuyer ces
efforts cela mais il faudra quand même
un certain temps à 27
c'est cette armée soit opérationnel il
faudra plusieurs semaines donc les
allemands le temps de s'installer autour
de paris et a commencé le siège de la
capitale alors au départ le gouvernement
est dans paris effectivement par décret
il avait été décidé de déplacer le une
partie gouvernement à tours ce qui fait
qu'on a on a à peu près deux têtes une
tête qui dirigera à partir de tours et
une tête principal qui dirige à partir
de paris d'où le départ
célèbre pour tous les écoliers des
années 60 70 soit on voyait gambetta
très jeune encore un il doit avoir 32
ans à ce moment là il est député de
paris les ministres de l'intérieur du
gouvernement provisoire il s'envole dans
un ballon pour aller à tour justement
d'où il va essayer d'organiser l'armée
de secours puissent réfugiera à bordeaux
déjà à l'époque comme en 40 on se
réfugie à bordeaux et mais il ya quelque
chose de très bas c'est nouveau dans ce
conflit bon il ya le train on l'a dit il
ya les enfants ne l'a pas dit mais je le
dis maintenant il ya les mitrailleuses
il ya l'artillerie la brutalisation de
la guerre et est terrible et puis à le
nombre de prisonniers pour la première
fois je crois que c'est 80 mille
prisonniers qui sont faits par les
allemands ou pendant les quatre premiers
mois de la guerre c'est énorme on
n'avait jamais vu ça
comment on gère des dizaines de milliers
de prisonniers
légère dans un premier temps à ces mêmes
parce que les prisonniers les 80 des
prisonniers de sedan notamment son son
parc et si on peut dire dans un coude de
la meuse qui s'appelle la presqu'île
tiges et les conditions qui règnent dans
ce camp de prisonniers sont sans
vraiment déplorable pendant une dizaine
de jours les les français sont livrés
livrés à eux mêmes ils vont commencer à
manquer de nourriture
il pleure plus après l'été les
magnifiques qu'on a eu on commence à
voir les les premières sérieuses depuis
l'automne on commence à manger ses
propres chevaux certaines certains
soldats essaye de passer la meuse à la
nage et sont accueillis de l'autre côté
par parler qu'au sien qui sont
sentinelle et c'est seulement à ce n'est
seulement book au bout de dix jours que
les prisonniers seront seront transférés
en allemagne
donc il a fallu je pense que il a fallu
qu'ils agissent en fonction des
conséquences quoi et ça va ça va
peut-être pas été prévu d'ailleurs les
les prussiens avait prévu des solutions
de répit derrière derrière le rhin au
cas où les choses tourneraient mal parce
que comme en 40 c'est assez curieux les
prussiens craignais vraiment l'armée
française à ce moment là mais ils ont
été presque surpris deux histoires aussi
rapide de sa désorganisation terribles
de ces erreurs tactiques ya aussi celles
tassement la quenelle à la réputation
que vont leur faire les français d'être
des barbares c'est alban on va accuser
la barbarie allemande les exactions
commises par l'armée allemande
on leur fera en 1914 ou leur fera
évidemment pendant la seconde guerre
mondiale et alors c'est le point de
départ de sa c'est quoi c'est qu'en fait
dans l'armée française vous le raconter
il ya ce qu'on appelle les mobiles et
les mobiles c'est des citoyens comme
vous et moi qui ont été appelés là pour
défendre la patrie qui n'ont pas
d'uniformes la plupart du temps qui ont
une cocarde et qui se bat contre les
allemands et pour les allemands ce ne
sont pas des soldats réguliers
donc on ne les traite pas comme des
soldats réguliers donc éventuellement
peut même les fusillés et c'est de là
que va naître la réputation de barbares
qu'on va faire aux allemands oui oui en
partie
je pense que c'est surtout surtout par
rapport aux actions coup de poing des
francs-tireurs les prussiens imprégné
vraiment les les francs tireurs qui
perpétraient des actions de guérilla sur
leur arrière sur leurs flancs quand
quand ils avançaient dans un pays qu'ils
commençaient à envahir et ce qui fait
que quand les frontières les francs
tireurs et plupart du temps s'appuyer
sur la population égale ment et quand on
les prussiens redevenait maistre du
terrain et qu'ils s'apercevaient que la
population s'était s'était rendu leur
avait prêté un coup de main elle a en
fait c'est là qu'ils commençaient à
faire après s'être procédé à des
exécutions et des représailles
ce qui fait que ce qui fait qu'en fait
on a vu beaucoup de villages incendiés
on a vu beaucoup de l'exécution sommaire
d'habitants qui avaient prêté main forte
aux francs tireurs
quant aux francs tireurs en fait n'avait
aucune chance de survie s'il est attrapé
par part de quotient
c'est d'ailleurs le l'origine du film le
début du film
la jument verte ça commence face à ce
genre de ce genre de faits vous savez
avec le bourvil et puis à ma politique
c'est la notion d'un roman de marcel
aymé voilà est en fait une sorte de
répétition de scarpe et soeurs repassera
pendant la seconde guerre mondiale entre
entre les allemands et la résistance qui
selon les lois de la guerre à l'époque
n'est pas considéré comme une armée
régulière donc on n'a pas à la traiter
avec les égards qu'on doit d un des
véritables prisonniers
donc on a deux cent mille prussiens qui
se dirige sur paris qui assiègent paris
et paris est défendue à la fois par par
une armée par des par des francs-tireurs
par des irréguliers mais aussi par des
forts il ya une trentaine de fort le
plus célèbre qui demeure aujourd'hui
c'est le mont valérien le fort du mont
valérien
mais à une trentaine de fortifications
avec de l'artillerie autour de paris et
le siège va durer quatre mois par un
hiver terrible il ya eu un été terrible
caniculaire et là il ya un univers
absolument glaçons qui va et le siège de
paris va durer pendant tout l'hiver et
ses et on s'en souvient encore
aujourd'hui puisqu'on parle de l'époque
où les parisiens manger duras et manger
aussi les animaux du jardin des plantes
un essai voir on a vraiment manger du
rapport on a mangé dur à victor hugo
parle d'ailleurs de de ces fameux pâté
de raki dont on parle dans dans la ville
et qui finalement ne serait pas si
mauvais que ça et vous parliez justement
du zoo et notamment on a battu le castor
et pollux qui étaient les deux éléphants
du jardin d'acclimatation dont on
retrouvera les les trompes
on y retrouvera des du boudin aussi dans
les chais les bouchers les plus huppés
de la ville
donc on en arrive aussi à manger du chat
du chien
tout va être bon pour pouvoir subsister
quoi sauf que bombe à bout d'un moment
où normalement finalement il n'y
absolument plus rien et c'est un petit
peu ce qui va précipiter ce qui se fait
à précipiter la chute de ben ali
ça commençait avant ça placerait les
interrompre ne brûlons pas les étapes
paris bombardé aussi c'est aussi c'est
une première
le pari bombardés par des puits par de
sacrés canon les canons krupp
à l'époque alors nous les français on a
encore des canons où il faut il faut
qu'on cherche par là par la gueule donc
le canonnier se met devant le canon et
par la même occasion les rives de stars
tués alors qu'ils ont les premiers
canaux où on reste derrière le canon et
sony vont par l'accusation
voilà donc sont beaucoup plus moderne et
puis surtout leurs canons sont beaucoup
plus précis et est ce que pour autant
paris bombardé souffre véritablement des
bombardements est ce que sont des
bombardements particulièrement ne
meurtrier est-ce que ça détruit
entièrement des bâtiments à l'époque où
est-ce que ça reste quand même
supportable alors c'est assez paradoxal
parce que effectivement il ya quand même
des morts le bombardement commence le 5
janvier exactement par l'effort du sud
puisque finalement c'est l'effort du sud
qui ont été empêchés de l'invasion
complète de paris d'époisses ya donc
l'effort du sud commence à être bien
d'attaquer et ensuite les allemands
relève un petit peu leur tir et
commencer à attaquer les quartiers sud
donc le 16e arrondissement et puis le
l'équivalent du 15e actuel 14e et peu à
peu relève encore leur mire et vont
aller jusqu'à au quartier de notre dame
de paris
mais comme le dit l'ambassadeur élus ou
ashburn l'ambassadeur américain qui est
en poste qui est l'un des derniers à
être ambassadeur étranger à être restée
rester à paris le nombre de ventes n'est
pas si n'est pas si élevé que ce qu'on
t'a quelques centaines et les parisiens
avaient en fait son centre est curieux
de des premiers bombardements ils vont
ni vont voir un peu les résultats comme
c'est comme s'il allait au spectacle
très souvent par contre ce qui choque
les parisiens à ce moment là ce sont les
bâtiments officiels et surtout les
hôpitaux militaires qui sont comme le
val de grâce et d'autres d'autres
endroits qui eux seront sont aussi visés
par les bombardements
d'ailleurs il va y avoir une lettre
officielle qui va être envoyée par tous
les diplomates et les autorités
médicales de la ville à volt pour lui
dire d'arrêter ce bombardement et
l'humain qui sont contraires aux lois de
la guerre
mais ce sera une fin de non recevoir
pour pour les français et donc ça va
continuer jusqu'à jusqu'à la fin du mois
ce qui est et ce qui est le plus
étonnant dans cette histoire tient et
des liasses c'est que en fait on a
quasiment oublié que paris a été assiégé
pendant quatre mois et que ça a été un
siège particulièrement dures souvient du
siège de leningrad on se souvient de de
toute sorte de siège pas du siège de
paris
oui c'est vrai alors c'est le siège de
paris en fait peut être inclus à
l'ensemble de la guerre finalement est
ce que c'est une guerre qui a été
complètement oublié des jeux elle est
humiliant pour la france puisqu'elle a
lu des réparations énorme 1,5 milliard
de francs or donc un quart du pib
français à ce moment là on a perdu lass
lorraine comme tout le monde le sait il
ya une occupation de trois ans paris a
été a été assis j'ai également
donc on a essayé un petit peu d'oublier
on a très vite penser à la revanche et
je pense que la victoire de 14 18 a
éclipsé un petit peu cette guerre donc
je pense que le siège de paris ne fait
pas exception à ça et il ya aussi une
autre chose c'est que très vite après le
siège de paris
on a eu les éléments tels que la commune
il tient encore une autre histoire donc
finalement il ya eu une succession de
choses qui fait que on est on est vite
passé à autre chose et on se rend compte
à ce moment là qu'il y à la même
opposition au fond en janvier 1871 qu'il
y aura en juin 40 entre ceux qui veulent
continuer la guerre à tout prix comme
gambetta qui lui à ce moment là se
trouve à bordeaux et ceux qui veulent
l'arrêter à tout prix comme tiers
adolphe thiers qui attend son heure et
qui va prendre le pouvoir à son tour il
ya la même opposition qui que l'on
retrouvera en 1940
c'est ça oui effectivement il ya une
pression plus comment il remonte
peut-être avant la guerre finalement
puisque tire déjà été en embuscade
venant but serait de reprendre le
pouvoir et et on s'aperçoit aussi qu'il
y a
il ya une presse qu'une sécession du
pays qui est qui aurait pu s'opérer ce
moment là sauf que bon vin le
gouvernement légitime qui se trouve à
paris qui est aussi à bordeaux également
envoie donc jules jules-simon d'un à
bordeaux pour essayer de faire piller
gambetta et il y arrive et gambetta va
démissionner à ce moment là et les
élections dont vont pouvoir passer
normalement mais c'est vrai quoi c'est
ce qui m'a frappé c'est que durant cette
guerre de 70 il ya des mouvements un
petit peu sécessionnistes comme par
exemple la d agitation aurait pu lui
républicaine qui se passe dans la dans
le midi de la france
ap la ligue du midi aussi donc on aurait
bien là très bien pu arriver à un
éclatement du pays du pays en deux
parties c'est le gouvernement qui siège
à paris et composé de d'une dizaine de
députés républicains parisien en tout
cas qui se trouvait à paris à ce pont là
et n'est pas forcément représentatif du
reste du pays qui lui était plutôt
bonapartiste ou en tout cas favorable à
l' empire il faut le rappeler que
napoléon quelques mois auparavant a
remporté à un plébiscite considérable et
et à ce moment là les républicains comme
jules favre pensait qu'ils avaient
vraiment plus rien à attendre de la
politique
en fait c'est vraiment l'erreur de
napoléon a été de 2 200 engagés dans
cette guerre qui va lui coûter son trône
mais là on voit bien et il ya des
élections
les républicains perdre les élections
lors des élections qui soient organisées
quand même dans des conditions assez
rocambolesque puisque on vient de perdre
la guerre c'est le bordel total
enfin les républiques à perdre les
élections et est fière et les
réactionnaires l'emportent c'est eux qui
vont négocier la paix et à ce moment là
elle s'est pas du tout gagné que la
république va rester un elle aurait très
bien pu
disparaître et qu'on rétablisse la
monarchie absolue où elle aurait très
bien pu disparaître en 1873 quand le
comte de chambord
voyant que la majorité est une majorité
royalistes revient en france après des
années d'exil et comment ça va prendre
des contre temps de contact avec
certains députés royaliste de la chambre
et puis ventes par an c'est bien connu
c'est finalement les discussions
achoppant sur sur la couleur du drapeau
il refusera absolument de conserver le
drapeau bleu blanc rouge pour vos
profits du drapeau blanc donc l'ancien
drapeau la royauté et à partir de ce
moment là finalement la république va
s'ancrer et surtout à partir de 10 75
avec les lois organiques
la loi constitutionnelle qui vont qui
vont régir justement la 3d la troisième
république policière qui est d'un tiers
qui prend le pouvoir à ce moment là il
faut rappeler que c'est un ancien
président du conseil des ministres du
roi louis philippe
donc il est c'est pas un perdreau de
l'année il arrive là et et lui il va
commettre il va être le premier
président au fond
et élus de cette troisième république
dont on ne connaît pas encore le nom ce
qu'elle n'est pas encore la troisième
république elle n'a pas de constitution
mais il va faire une erreur lui aussi va
vouloir retirer les canons de montmartre
et c'est ce qui va déclencher la commune
mais ça c'est un sujet que vous traitez
pas devant votre livre j'imagine qu'on a
on commémorera son 150e anniversaire
l'année prochaine en 2021
mais on voit bien que que dans cette
affaire il ya une sorte de répétition de
la plupart des conflits qui vont qui
vont suivre
y compris au 20e siècle il ya les
communistes enfin il ya les communards
il y allait y aller réactionnaire il ya
les républicains il ya l'allemagne à la
france
et tout ça va se rejouer deux fois en 14
18 puis en 39 45
oui et d'ailleurs ce qui est étonnant
c'est que l'ambassadeur wisdom que je
dont j'ai étudié les mémoires pour ce
livre parle de deux événements qui ont
lieu donc le premier s'est ouvert le 29
octobre un soulèvement de communards de
ce qu'ils vont devenir les communards
six mois plus tard et un deuxième
soulèvement le 22 janvier qu'il apprend
comment occasionne quand même des morts
sur la place de l'hôtel de ville et à
chaque fois en fait ouais je leur ai dit
que la république rouge
il est en train d'être en train de
soulever les petits pains il utilise le
mot rouge donc c'est quelque chose c'est
quand même bien en très bien à ventre ce
qui est puis à la révolution oui c'est
donc moi ça m'a fait ça m'avait étonné
sa merci thierry nébias vous avez fait
un vrai travail d'historien dans ce
livre donc l'humiliante défaite qui est
paru à la librairie vibert ont fait une
pause et on se retrouve avec aliocha
aval de la surf ski qui va nous dévoiler
les cinq secrets de james bond
[Musique]
jean soit maintenant aliocha valdes
lasowski professeur des universités
bonjour vous enseigner la philosophie
politique à sciences po lille en master
et vous publié chez max milo
les cinq secrets de james bond pour vous
les 25 films de james bond ne relève pas
seulement du divertissement populaire ce
n'est pas uniquement une franchise qui a
rapporté des milliards à ses producteurs
c'est plus intéressant que star wars
parce que juste deux choses ben oui
c'est ça qui est intéressant avec
maintenant 60 ans de cinéma de la saga
james bond qui a commencé exactement 62
et qui elle même est une adaptation de
romans de ian fleming qu'il a commencé à
écrire dans sa villa qui s'appelle
goldeneye en jamaïque en 52 53
donc on a 60 ans de cinéma bientôt
vingt-cinq films et je pense
qu'effectivement on pourrait alors au
delà de l'aventuré de l'espionnage
divertissement même parfois de scènes un
peu kitsch période roger moore par
exemple on pourrait tout à fait voir la
saga de james bond comme une épopée
arthurienne comme effectivement une
histoire d' aventure mais aussi
finalement mythologique qui renvoie
presque à l'odyssée d'ulysse
donc je trouve qu'on peut analyser
effectivement cette saga comme
finalement faisant partie de notre
culture contemporaine d'aujourd'hui mais
au sens mythologique pratiquement de
roland barthes c'est à dire quelque
chose qui nous a accompagné et aux fonds
qui aujourd'hui peut être un objet alors
moi je pense pas qu'il fallait le
prendre comme un objet de nostalgie mais
la saga james bond à évoluer avec son
temps et finalement c'est un regard
aussi sur l'époque sur les années 60 70
80 jusqu'à aujourd'hui et je trouve que
c'est un bon élan finalement c'est ça
finalement un mythe un ou une épopée
c'est un mélange entre différence et
répétition c'est à dire qu'on retrouve
dans la saga de james bond des éléments
récurrents la fameuse je pense que c'est
la ritournelle la plus célèbre du cinéma
my name is bond james bond quoi que vous
parliez de star wars
je suis ton père c'est aussi une
ritournelle célèbre mais disons qu'on a
par exemple le fameux
cocktail vodka martini secoué méningite
et qu'on retrouve de film en film ô vous
miss moneypenny qui accueille james bond
à chaque fois qu'ils arrivent au bureau
du mi6 et pourtant la répétition dont il
est pourtant différence aussi parce que
je pense que les personnages ont évolué
que les rapports hommes femmes ont
évolué que le contexte géopolitique a
changé et que james bond dit quelque
chose de notre temps et de notre époque
et alors pour vous il ya donc cinq
secrets que vous nous dévoiler dans ce
livre le premier d'ordre géopolitique
c'est que vous nous dites qu'au fond
james bond et là vous parlez des films
james du monde anticipe les évolutions à
la fois de la guerre froide puisqu'une
grande partie de des films de james bond
se passe se déroule pendant la guerre
froide mais aussi de l'après guerre
froide
au fond il est y tiendra un rôle de
vigie de la géopolitique à l'avenir
alors à quoi vous voyez vous ça il ya
deux éléments qui peuvent aller dans ce
sens c'est d'une part qu'effectivement
la saga de james bond apparaît en 1962
sur les écrans à la grande première
c'est à londres au royal albert hall ans
le 5 octobre 1962 et trois jours plus
tard se déclenche
finalement la crise des missiles à cuba
qui commence à ce moment là et donc on
est déjà plongé dans quelque chose qui
est effectivement le contexte
géopolitique bipolaire de la guerre
froide
mais ce qui est intéressant c'est qu'en
fait la saga james bond accompagne donc
les événements politiques géopolitiques
mais en donnant évidemment un rôle un
peu plus important à la grande bretagne
pour redorer finalement le l'image de la
grande-bretagne et pour essayer de faire
en sorte que l ne soit pas seulement ce
qui se passe dans la réalité dans les
années 60 qu'elle ne soit pas seulement
l'allié des etats-unis contre l'urss
contre le bloc soviétique et on voit
très bien que dans les films par exemple
tout premier docteur no vous avez
évidemment le méchant comme comme 10
heures elle ferait d'hitchcock c'est les
grands méchants qui font les grands
films dr know it le 1
un adversaire de james bond mais un
adversaire des deux camps de l'est et de
l'ouest des états unis et des
soviétiques
parce que il a détourné de l'argent des
chinois et il va travailler pour une
organisation terroriste qui s'appelle
spectre et qu'on va retrouver de film en
film et donc effectivement ça nous
arrache finalement au contexte
géopolitique mais ça c'est un point qui
est intéressant et qui montrent qu'au
final la presse vous pas de vous
interrompre et qui va ce qui va
accompagner en fait toute l'existence de
gentlemen vous dites qu'au fond il est
très rarement contre la russie contre
l'urss vie ou même contre le kgb james
bond il va même être il n'est pas contre
eux au fond qui fait il paris il leur
arrive même assez souvent de travailler
la main dans la main et vous rappeler
que dans 185 dont rien que pour vos yeux
je crois il est décoré de l'ordre
de lénine c'est pas du tout un ennemi du
bloc soviétique
non non c'est vrai c'est même le général
gogol qui vient lui offrir la médaille
dans le bureau du mi6 effectivement dans
le contexte des années 80 où la tension
la guerre froide a redémarré a repris un
nouvel élan en fait dans les films vous
avez le général beau vol qui est
finalement l'équivalent de m
au du mi6 et à dire le chef du kgb qui
m'a souvent rencontré james bond ou ses
homologues et eelv ont sympathisé contre
un ennemi supérieur par exemple dans
l'espion qui m'aimait c'est karl
stromberg qui veut effectivement noyer
la planète d'être le monde et donc les
russes et les britanniques vont s'allier
ensemble et puis finalement regarder ce
qui est amusant c'est que deviennent les
états unis bah c'est le fameux agent de
la cia felix leiter qui est le copain
depuis toujours de james bond conséquent
il reçoit d'ailleurs dans dans voilà on
voulait pas tomber exactement il sera là
aussi il est là depuis le début
depuis depuis dr no est en fait lui il
est souvent avec la reste à l'épaule a
regardé james bond alors ça avance la
mission et c'est donc il est plutôt
sympathique bien sûr mais on voit très
bien que voilà dans le film c'est plutôt
la cia qui s'allie avec avec le mi6
plutôt que l'inversé et c'est ce que
vous disent ce que vous dites dans votre
livre c'est que l'enjeu de la bataille
de james bond c'est pas tellement la
domination du monde c'est plutôt le soft
power
c'est pas le hard power c'est le soft
power oui parce que ce qui est
intéressant je trouve c'est qu'au final
les comptes bien sûr il ya des
affrontements des conflits des batailles
j'allais dire et pique parfois dans
l'est dans les films bien sûr on attend
sur la grande scène de fin où il ya
souvent l'attaquent des forces alliées
contre le contre l'ennemi mais ce qui
est intéressant oui le soft power c'est
quoi c'est à dire qu'en fait les parties
de conflits se règlent souvent autour
d'une table de casino une table de jeu
et donc c'est là aussi évidemment que
les coups de bluff les coups de poker
comme on dit et qui sont dans la
géopolitique des sortes d'armes qu'on
utilise pour faire croire à l'adversaire
telle ou telle stratégie est en fait
c'est pas celle là qu'on utilise
finalement la table de casino dans les
films de james bond représente la scène
géopolitique et je trouve ça très
intéressant de voir comment les conflits
se règlent d'une certaine façon autour
d'une partie de baccarat autour d'un
cocktail martini ou d'un jeu de cartes
alors le deuxième secret que vous voyez
dans les films de james bond c'est que
jack du monde c'est à la fois un sujet
britannique et en même temps il est
profondément cosmopolite c'est à dire
que c'est le contraire d'un nationaliste
et c'est le contraire dan identitaire au
fond c'est le contraire 2 717 ou du
mollah parodique que quand on en a fait
en france avec avec jean dujardin
d'autant plus parodique que es s et
société les services secrets américains
et que donc on a un agent secret
français qui travaillent en réalité pour
les services secrets américains enfin
bon passons ce détail mes enfants voient
bien ce qui est drôle chez oss 117 joué
par dujardin c'est qu'il est
nationaliste il est identitaire il est
complètement con alors que alors que
john pas du tout james bond il est
traversé par absolument toutes les
cultures il les connaît toutes les oui
vous avez tout à fait raison c'est à
dire qui il est patriote c'est certain
il est fidèle à la couronne à sa majesté
on a évidemment tous les éléments
britanniques réunies dans le dans les
films même le charme le flegme anglais
le l'humour anglais ont paralysé
vraiment les dialogues aussi sur la la
question typique de la manière de parler
britannique on a les codes
évidemment qu'ils sont là les décors
sont britanniques il ya toute une
ambiance évidemment au départ qu'il est
et pourtant j'ai l'impression que cette
à partir de cette identité james bond à
s'arracher presque à ce qu'on lui colle
à la peau
c'est à dire effectivement qu'il est un
agent secret qui a un format une norme
standard bien défini et effectivement
ils s'adaptent à des univers très
différents ils arrivent à se
métamorphoser il a une sorte d'hybride
it et finalement c'est un personnage
beaucoup plus souple beaucoup plus
malléable qui se transforme un peu au
fur et à mesure des missions et par
exemple effectivement lorsqu'il est au
jeu
conte dans on ne vit que deux fois il
véritablement il s'adapte à d'autres
codes culturels
il s'adapte à d'autres langues miss
moneypenny lui dis n oubliez pas partir
à votre avec votre petit dictionnaire de
traduction pour cette mission et lui dit
non non non j'ai un doctorat de langues
orientales je sais je parle très bien
le japonais est effectivement on voit
que dans le film il connaît très bien
les colonnes il sait très bien comment
boire du sac est par exemple évidemment
que la boisson chez james bond est un
peu un critère pour voir comment le
personnage se place dans le décor de
l'environnement et par exemple ils
montrent très bien qu'il sait
parfaitement préparé le sac et voir le
sac et le déguster à à la bonne
température
et ça c'est un signe évidemment c'est un
détail mais par exemple il connaît bien
les arts martiaux il connaît bien
évidemment des techniques de combat
japonaise donc dans ce film là qui est
un film où on voit comment james bond
finalement s'adapte à un environnement
différent
finalement il représente la mondialité
c'est à dire ils représentent
l'hybridation des cultures la
transformation des cultures les unes par
les autres et et d'ailleurs il fait ça
pas seulement avec les japonais avec les
arabes ont donc tout le monde hein il
est toujours partout chez lui comme les
rois et les voleurs j'ai envie de dire
et ils vont le fait remarquer d'ailleurs
que de du tout les interprètes de james
bond
il n'y en a que deux qui étaient qui
sont anglais roger moore daniel craig
tous les autres sont extérieurs à
l'angleterre
sean connery est écossais pierce brosman
irlandais timothy dalton et gallois et
george lazenby
le héros de service secret de sa majesté
et australiens donc là aussi sa part
fait le parfait le la résolution que
c'est de ce petit paradoxe troisième
secret ce serait pas d'après vous james
bond lettres viril et misogynes que l'on
croit au fond c'est quoi alors ça
romantique alors c'est intéressant parce
qu'évidemment on a une image de james
bond qui incarne d'ailleurs à juste
titre puisque c'est comme ça que c'est
mis en avant dans l'est dans les films
l'homme moderne la viguerie la virilité
même le machisme en tout cas un certain
style de domme et dont les les femmes ne
sont là évidemment que pour l'entourer
en tout cas et le mettre en valeur et je
pense qu'il faut essayer de voir un peu
les choses autrement
parce que dès les premiers films moi
j'appelle pas ça les james bond girl
je l'appelle plutôt salée james bond
lady's parce que je trouve que les
femmes aux seins un rôle soit d'ailleurs
deux elles mêmes des espionnes ou des
agents secrets qui sont au même niveau
que que james bond dans certaines
missions par exemple la l'espionnage
soviétique de l'espion qui m'aimait
effectivement et s'appelle triple x elle
est envoyée par le général goble en
mission et elle est à égalité avec avec
james bond et c'est eux on voit
d'ailleurs il ya un duel à un moment
donné pour savoir si la base de cartes
stromberg se trouve soit en sardaigne
soit en sicile et les deux espions ne
sont pas tout à fait d'accord et on voit
très bon que voilà james bond n'a pas
toujours raison c'est pas toujours lui
qui a le dernier mot il fait des erreurs
et ses alliés qui sont des espionnes
sont tout à fait évidemment à la hauteur
de 2 des missions qui sont confiées à
ces deux personnages mais il ya aussi
autre chose c'est que il ya un film clé
qui est au service de sa majesté de 1969
où pour la première fois james bond se
marient et la fin ils malheureusement
tragique puisque l'épousé de james bond
meurs tu es par justement le grand
ennemi en scrabble feld qu'on retrouvera
dans les épisodes suivants
et depuis cette scène tragique depuis ce
moment tragique
j'ai l'impression que james bond
recherche plutôt que effectivement la
séduction facile ou voilà des aventures
je pense qu'ils recherchent ce que
j'appelle dans le livre le sur mariage
c'est à dire qu'on a une comédie
romantique qui s'installe dans la
comédie d'espionnage et james bond
s'attache aux personnages féminins est
il même il a souvent envie de se marier
même temps daniel craig dans lorsqu'il
va à venise avec des sports line à la
fin de casino royale
il propose de vivre avec elle et
d'arrêter d'être d'arrêter son métier
d'espion donc james bond je pense a
envie d'une seule chose c'est de
s'installer de vivre une vie ordinaire
et d'arracher lui-même cette étiquette
qu'on lui colle souvent à la coupe et
moi j'irais même plus loin vous je pense
que il n'est pas aussi hétéronormée
qu'on le croit il lui arrive de tomber
dans la coquetterie même sean connery
tombe de la coquetterie dans je crois
que c'est dans goldfinger où ils
arborent des maillots de bain des tenues
de plage qui sont quand même sidérante
et et puis roger moore ensuite avec ses
petits blousons étriqué ses pantalons
moulants
on voit bien qu'il ait pas du tout ils
sont pas aussi aussi hétéro normes et
qu'on le dit alors je suis absolument
d'accord avec vous et d'ailleurs même je
le dis aussi dans le livre il ya un
chapitre s'appelle l'espion s'habille en
prada qui montre aussi effectivement que
tous les codes vestimentaires sont
finalement transformées réinventé par
par james bond et que la séduction n'est
pas forcément uniquement tournée vers
les femmes mais la séduction est aussi
tournée vers les hommes donc de ce point
de vue là effectivement les normes sont
totalement renversé je trouve par james
bond et on doit justement vous avez tout
à fait raison voir aussi cette évolution
cette transformation du personnage dans
ses relations otan avec les hommes
qu'avec les femmes
le quatrième secret
concernerait le corps de james bond
c'est vrai que c'est un héros physique
mais en quoi son corps est il
particulier je trouve que contrairement
aux super héros qu'on voit aujourd'hui
effectivement dans les sagas ou dans les
séries james bond a malgré tout un côté
à la fois sombre non seulement sombre
mais aussi un côté vulnérable fragile il
se blesse souvent on le voit avec le
bras dans le plâtre
par exemple dans skyfall avec daniel
craig il doit repasser des tests
d'aptitude physique qu'il va d'ailleurs
échoué et donc james bond finalement non
seulement vieilli parce que c'est normal
on a aussi une évolution presque du
personnage mais j'ai l'impression que
son corps est beaucoup plus fragile est
beaucoup plus incertain et que j'ai
essayé d'analyser justement regarder les
titres des films déjà où il ya le mot
mourir qui est là en permanence
on a l'impression que james bond est
plutôt quand même au bord du fossé qu'il
n'est pas le super héros qu'on croit
qu'il a beaucoup de failles
il a d'ailleurs une blessure au bas du
dos il a d'ailleurs raté les morts dans
une ville de foix il meurt voilà il ya
plusieurs scènes effectivement
d'enterrement et j'ai même analyse et
voilà le nombre de scènes où il est en
train d humeur au début de on vit que
deux fois il
il meurt il ya des fausses morts
évidemment dans certains films il ya des
pierres tombales qui marque qui prennent
même les initiales de james bond dans
vivre et laisser mourir
donc on a l'impression que will qu'il ya
une forme de résurrection c'est un peu
un phoenix james bond il meurt plusieurs
fois en fait si on regarde bien les
films il a plusieurs façons de mourir
presse et de ressusciter de se
retransformer donc c'est un personnage
voilà qui qui n'a pas finalement une vie
aussi aussi défini aussi maîtriser qu'on
le croit et la mort arrive à plusieurs
reprises dans la saga est au fond il est
et il est pour vous il est il est très
différent des super héros qui eux aussi
ont
ont formé une une franchise la franchise
marvel extrêmement lucrative 1 les trois
franchises les plus lucratif de
l'histoire du cinéma c'est star wars
marvel et jam du monde mais lui ça n'est
pas un super héros c'est un super héros
mais sans l'être
bah oui c'est vrai qu' évidemment on est
dans une franchise qui a ses codes
depuis 60 ans et qui a battu des records
même récemment vous savez ce que skyfall
le film avec avec daniel craig et la
magnifique chanson d'adèle a totalement
battu tous les tous les records du box
office
plus d'un milliard de recettes donc
évidemment reste je vous arrête
malheureusement parce que vous êtes
victime de la propagande des studios
hollywoodiens qui nous font croire
qu'ils battent des records quand il
n'embarque pas il se trouve que le prix
du ticket de cinéma ayant évidemment
étant beaucoup plus cher aujourd'hui du
temps de dr no en réalité skyfall compte
on nous dit qu'il est le ils étaient les
50e anniversaire on nous a dit là bas
qui tous les records
non les trois films les plus lucratifs
de la saga james bond vous savez ce que
c'est en fait le premier c'est le condor
thunder boels et opération tonnerre
le deuxième c'est goldfinger et le
troisième seulement c'est skyfall mais
pour le savoir il faut convertir
évidemment ce que ça a rapporté à
l'époque dans le monde
avec l'inflation des tickets de cinéma
en france on compte les spectateurs les
américains préfèrent compter les dollars
ça leur permet de battre des records
toutes les semaines
même quand il embête pas en réalité et
c'était un petit pois vous avez raison
effectivement qu'il faut pour replacer
chaque sortie de film dans son contexte
économique il ya bien sûr à re voir tout
à fait par rapport au nombre de
spectateurs la rentabilité mais en tout
cas pour simplement si vous me permettez
cette analyse c'est que james bond en
tout cas ne dépérit pas et par rapport à
ses concurrents garde toujours
évidemment une place particulière dans
le coeur des spectateurs du monde entier
et donc effectivement ce que ce qu'on
pouvait dire là se penser que voilà
c'est une saga effectivement qu'ils
apportent à chaque fois son lot
évidemment de référence de code et
datant du et je pense qu'il va quand
même se développer davantage que les
autres sagas parce que comme vous savez
le prochain film mourir peut attendre et
le dernier de daniel craig
donc la productrice barbara broccoli
cherche évidemment à un successeur un
remplaçant à diane à daniel craig et là
aussi on a beaucoup de spéculations
beaucoup d'idées mais moi je trouverais
formidable par exemple que on sait qu'il
ya une actrice la chana lynch qui joue
dans le prochain une espionne du mi6
peut-être que effectivement james bond
sera sera une femme ou en tout cas on a
on a beaucoup de prétendants pour
remplacer james bond et les choses vont
encore évoluer donc le personnage va
aussi se transformer par les acteurs et
les actrices qu'il incarne alors 5e
secret vous en avez trouvé comptait 5 1
c'est le titre de votre livre le
cinquième secret baisse et que le
premier film de james bond sort
quasiment le même jour en 1962 que le
premier 45 tours des beatles
vous n'avez jamais remarqué cette
coïncidence love me do est sorti le même
jour où avec quelques heures près que le
que les feux de jour que le premier film
le dr no avec sean connery
c'est incroyable comme toi mais quelles
conclusions en tirez-vous
bajeux j'en tire une conclusion
évidemment on pourrait simplement voir
ça comme une comme une coïncidence
d'époque mais ça dit quelque chose aussi
sur la sur la pop culture et aussi sur
notre culture contemporaine parce que
évidemment pour nous aujourd'hui
james bond comme les beatles d'une
certaine façon sont des classiques sont
des classiques des années 60
et évidemment on peut les voir à la fois
comme des figures aujourd'hui intemporel
éternelle qui ont marqué leur époque et
qui continueront a marqué des
générations et en même temps comme
quelque chose qui va bouleverser
seulement les rapports entre classique
et moderne parce que ce qui est
intéressant dans l'est dans les james
bond c'est qu'il ya des références à des
musiques tout à fait contemporaine à des
voitures tout à fait moderne à des
marques de champagne qui sont dans l'air
du temps et en même temps à des musiques
classiques à des oeuvres intemporel donc
il ya un mélange entre le classique et
le moderne dans la saga james bond et
sert forment un cocktail assez
intéressant aussi à regarder aujourd'hui
avec le décalage avec le temps mais oui
cette sortie cette coïncidence de sortie
entre les beatles et james bond c'est
quand même la naissance la naissance
effectivement d'une nouvelle génération
de la pop et de d'un côté de la musique
pop et de l'autre du cinéma pop je
pourrais dire et et de l' influence des
anglais au fond sur ces zones des 60
dieu sait si leur influence peut être
considérable alors là on parle de soft
power c'est extraordinaire à la fois la
l'invasion britannique c'est comme ça
que les américains ne le verront à
partir des beatles et de tous les
groupes anglais et de james bond qui est
effectivement un produit anglais au
départ mais pas par cette querelle entre
les anciens et les modernes moi je
trouve que james bond il y avait porté
sur le classicisme à la fois son
élégance et classique à part quand c'est
roger moore sa culture est classique il
y fait référence dans tous les domaines
vous le disiez il a très bon goût
c'est un arbitre du bon goût et d'un bon
goût intemporel c'est ses références
sont classiques qui passe son temps à
venise vous le faites remarquer il
revient tout le temps à venice les
beatles et le contraire les beatles
suivent toutes les modes il en invente
un certain nombre mais ils vont tout les
suivre ils vont jamais à venise les
beatles ça les intéresse pas et on voit
bien ils vont ils vont ils voient
refuser toutes les modes vestimentaires
même les plus les plus
ridicule ils vont se laisser pousser les
cheveux la barbe etc
les beatles de 1969 n'ont plus rien à
voir avec habitat de 1962 alors que
james bond lui reste james bond au fond
oui c'est vrai que vous avez raison on
ne voit pas un james bond hippie par
exemple dans un dé dans un des films
mais ce qui est intéressant c'est qu'il
ya aussi finalement du côté des
adversaires de james bond une
incarnation aussi de ceux de ce
classicisme donc l2 finalement alors
soit on verrait les films comme un
affrontement entre entre finalement le
classique james bond contre ses ennemis
qui eux aussi sont classiques par
exemple il ya un travaux blofeld dans
les diamants sont éternels qui cite la
rochefoucauld il ya une citation de la
rochefoucauld qui est d'ailleurs pas
tout à fait exact dans l'utilisation
même de cette maxime
mais en tout cas on voit qu'il ya des
références évidemment aux classiques car
stromberg à des teintures des dorures
dans son dans sa base secrète qui re qui
renvoie évidemment à des tableaux de la
renaissance qu'il essaie d'imiter
de son côté james bond est aussi un
classique qui va évidemment son nom même
son nom même c'est le symbole du
classicisme puisque c'est une synthèse
entre autre bond street et saint-james
tweets qui sont deux rues anglaises où
il ya les les couturiers où il y avait
évidemment le plus ancien club de
gentleman de l'angleterre de londres et
donc james bond qu'il ya dans les faits
dans les romans de ian fleming qui a
fait ses études dans les collèges les
plus huppés les plus classiques
d'angleterre évidemment à une formation
une formation classique et un esprit
très très classique donc voilà à partir
de quel moment il reste dans ce cadre à
partir de quel moment il en sort parfois
comme peut le faire de temps en temps
évidemment certains certains acteurs ou
certains certaines incarnation de james
bond qui est peut-être par exemple avec
avec timothy dalton
on a un james bond qui s'américanise
presque d'une certaine façon qui est
plus dans dans l'action pure dans dans
une certaine forme de violence et en
même temps il ya aussi chez james bond
une bestialité
il est brut de décoffrage c'est un être
aussi qui est à la fois sophistiquée qui
a à la fois les codes de la
sophistication et en même temps qu'il ya
une forme de u voilà de bestialité c'est
un être de chair c'est un être aussi de
corps qui souffre parfois qui lutte
aussi parfois contre contre lui-même
donc assez de ces deux aspects c'était
évidemment un un être d'image c'est un
james bond est à quasiment un personnage
qui a une image presque éternel vous
l'avait dit et en même temps qu'il ya
des failles qui vont apparaître au fur
et à mesure des films et qui le rendent
psychologiquement plus complexe je pense
notamment et c'est ce qui a renouvelé
aussi un petit peu la saga ce cas il
faut les spectres on voit très bien que
james bond et torturé que il va même
voir une docteure doctoresse qui
s'appelle madeleine swan évidemment qui
est un personnage qui fait allusion à
proust personnage proustien et en même
temps voilà il a des problèmes avec son
enfance il a des problèmes aussi
lui-même psychologique il doit régler et
finalement on voit que voilà rien n'est
encore achevé que derrière l'armure se
brise un petit peu voilà le glamour de
façade et les gadgets en trompe l'oeil
merci lieu chaval dans surf ski merci
d'avoir participé à cette émission les
cinq secrets de james bond est paru chez
max milo merci de nous avoir suivis et
rendez vous au prochain numéro
[Musique]